With medical and recreational marijuana legalization
spreading across the country
Reason attended the Cannabis World Congress
and Business Exposition in New York City
to get a sense of where things are headed
with commercialized weed
and weed related products.
We encountered retired pro football players
promoting non psychoactive CBD oils
that they say have replaced the opioids they
once needed to dull their pain.
If it wasn't for a company like Elixinol and
the products that we produce
I don't know where I'd be right now.
We sampled cold brewed coffee infused with
a marijuana extract that won't get you stoned
but still makes for a calmer morning.
It helps minimize the jitters in cold brew
coffee.
We learned why candy is the go-to product
for edibles.
If you're smoking and you get the munchies
and you want that extra high
what are you gonna go for?
A quick snack, so you have your edibles and
you have your weed, you're elevated.
And we talked to an attorney who's going state
by state where weed is legal
to fight for laws that clear away the criminal
records of nonviolent drug offenders.
If you're going to make something legal
continuing to burden them with a lifelong
criminal record makes no sense.
But by far the most vision inducing part of
the conference was keynote speakers Billy Tauzen.
He's a former conservative congressman from
Louisiana who went on to head up PhRMA
the pharmaceutical industry's massive lobbying
group.
Now he works for Lenitiv Labs, a medical cannabis
company
founded by TV host, MS sufferer and long time
legalization advocate Montel Williams.
Tauzen himself survived a life threatening
bout with cancer
and now he says he wishes he could have smoked
weed to ease his pain.
Took 65 pounds off of me, beat the hell outta
me,
I'm watching patients today take advantage
of medical marijuana products
and get through that a lot easier.
And I'm thinking 'wow, why didn't we have
that opportunity when I went through it
15 years ago.'
Do all former congressmen have to get cancer
before we're gonna get medical marijuana or
recreational marijuana?
God I hope not and I hope most members of
Congress don't have to go through that.
I told the group today I think we took a silent
vote, a secret ballot,
we'd win them more easily.
If you were a member of Congress and you've
been taught all your life that this is a bad entry drug
that's gonna get your children addicted and
they're gonna become a life of drug addicts
or what have you
you've got some convincing on your hands,
right?
You've gotta somehow say 'no that's not what
we're talking about
we're talking about adult use, we're talking
about medical use,
we're talking about something very different
that's been kept from you and the public for years
by simply bad policy and sort of dark age
thinking.
We somehow have to educate them that it's
literally in their interest to make changes in policy
Why? because their constituents want them
to.
You were also the head of PhRMA, the lobbying
group for the pharmaceutical industry
a lot of people in the legalization space
are worried that big pharma
is going to try to keep marijuana from becoming
legal.
Are those concerns warranted?
The pharmaceutical industry is all about finding
new medicines
and when it's legally possible for them to
go to the FDA with medical marijuana products
they're going to be doing that.
As I told the group today they're probably
gonna want to come around and see you.
If you've already pioneered these medicines
and you've got them in the marketplace.
They're going to want to talk to you about
acquiring your companies one day.
They're in that business for Christ's sake.
No I don't think they're gonna fight it, I
think they're gonna probably watch, wait and see
if the legalization spreads as I think it
will around the country
congress wakes up and, you know, passes the
laws that take it off the schedules
and let them become investigators and researchers
into the exact why and how it works,
I think they're going to be partners with
this group today.
You just got to literally take some time for
it to happen.
Tauzen has never been a full on libertarian.
But his experiences have taught him a valuable
lesson about self ownership.
And he supports the right to try bill recently
signed by Donald Trump
giving terminally ill patients access to experimental
medications.
Libertarians have it right there, we ought
to have a right to our own body and our own protection
if I want to try something new I'll have the
right to try it.
I hate the notion that, as I told the group
today, that the medicine that saved my life
is off label and the company can't tell other
people that it could be useful pancreatic medicine
they can only use it for the label, that it's
labeled for.
At least we ought to open that up
we ought to let people talk about the real life experiences with medicines
and which ones help which people.
One thing I've learned is how different we
are biologically
and the medicine that's going to work for
you may not work for me
we ought to be able to tell those stories,
be able to share them on the internet,
learn from them.
Yeah there's going to be some mistakes maybe
but I'd love to live in that world
rather than one that denies us access to something
that could save our lives.
Donald Trump has said, at the urging of Cory
Gardner, Republican senator from Colorado
that he would sign a bill returning marijuana
laws and regulation to the states
are you confident that he will do that if
presented with that
and, you know, will Congress actually write
something and vote on something?
Two good questions, as to the first:
I think one day Congress will, if we literally
advocate properly
I think they wanna do that, it's just a question
of giving them the courage to do it.
As to Trump keeping his word?
You may not like him one bit, but he keeps
his word.
And whatever he told you in that campaign
he's following through on it.
To a lot of people's consternation.
He's doing exactly what he said he would.
When he says he'd sign that bill, I have no
doubt he'd sign it.
One final question, what's the timeline for
full legalization of marijuana?
Is it ten years, is it fifteen years, is it
already happening and you know,
we'll go outside of this convention center
and it'll be a done deal?
I've learned something about the progress
of mankind
any time you try to predict it's gonna take
longer than you think
you're probably wrong.
This is moving fast, this tide has turned,
we're past the tipping point
ain't no coming back, I think this is going
to happen within five years.